do you want your multi-cloud deployments
to be boring or like a roller coaster
i'm chris lozaro from ibm and i'm going
to talk to you about gitops
for multi-cloud
but before i do that please be sure to
like and subscribe
the approach we're going to talk about
today is simple
consistent
and secure
now typically when
[Music]
customers are building applications they
start out with an on-prem environment
and they have a gui and a cli for
managing
that environment
but then they want to
move to the cloud and utilize cloud
environments so they start using
a cloud
and it has its own gui
and its own cli
and things get a little bit more
complicated
and now they have hybrid cloud apps that
are stretching across on-prem and cloud
and
these different environments can be
difficult to manage
but the advantages of cloud are there
and so they continue and now they add
additional clouds
in order to have the flexibility to move
their applications from one cloud to the
next or use multiple clouds for
different purposes
so now you've have gui and cli across
your on-prem your first cloud and any
other cloud that you're using
and things start to become pretty
difficult
now open openshift helps
openshift provides a secure consistent
way of managing
your infrastructure and applications
no matter whether they're on-prem or in
the cloud
but we're going to take things a step
further and show how git ops
can really manage everything through git
operations
so you have your dev team
and they are used to doing all of their
work inside of git so source code is all
managed within git
and you have your ops team
and they're in charge of managing all of
your different environments
so how do we bring dev and ops together
well we can set up
repositories for infrastructure
for services
and for the applications
so when we go and look at your deployed
environments
your dev
your test
and your prod environments
can all be managed in your
infrastructure repo
and then when you start deploying
services that your application depends
on things like a messaging service
that can be managed as well in the
services repo
and then the application itself you've
got your application the source code
continues to be managed in the
application repo so when you deploy that
you've got your front end and your back
end
that again is all managed in get
and so rather than using the different
management consoles
when you check into git
you've got tools that are automatically
ensuring your git environment manages
and matches your production environment
so as changes are made over here
they get deployed and
mimicked over here so that they match
now one funny story is when we were
demoing this to a customer we started
setting up this whole environment
and so
we had our git repo but git is pretty
boring to demo no one wants to see a
pull request
and we started showing openshift but no
matter where we were whether we're
on-prem in our one cloud or another
cloud openshift looked exactly the same
so we started to pull up the individual
management consoles and we realized we
don't even have access to the
third-party management console the team
that was setting this up was using a
shared account that had been locked down
so
even even demoing this stuff we were
showing the value of gitops because it
was
very secure in the fact that we didn't
even have access to show those
management consoles
so get ops is an approach that's simple
consistent and secure for managing your
environments
you don't have to be like a roller
coaster you can have boring deployments
across multi-cloud
thank you if you have any questions
please drop us a line below and if you
want to see more videos like this in the
future please like and subscribe